game installs are out of control and
hard drive space is barely keeping up
even on the latest next gen consoles
in this video we're going to show you
some of the biggest game installs of all
time
keep in mind that this video is a
snapshot in time and install sizes can
and will change
quick ground rules games had to be over
100 gigs which included their dlc and
high resolution texture packs
if you want to see more video game lists
including our top 10 games of 2020
please hit that subscribe button and
give us a thumbs up
let's get to it
call of duty modern warfare 2019 this
game was in my opinion a once in a
decade call of duty title that did it
all
changed the look and feel of weapons had
clever map design in spades
boasted incredible post launch support
provided the best take on battle royale
and i'm gonna say it
even had a great storefront that was
free of loot boxes but oh boy were you
in for a shock when you looked at your
hard drive
on my ps4 this clocked in at 252
gigabytes
thankfully space-saving features have
been added to the game more recently you
can now remove single-player
spec ops and high-resolution textures
but now that modern warfare is more
manageable
there's another call of duty game which
is why we're going to number two
call of duty black ops cold war this
year we were excited to get next gen
consoles and when an xbox series x
arrived we installed one of the newest
playable games
only to find out that it ate up over a
quarter of all usable hard drive space
at launch it roughly broke down to a
hundred and eighty six point five
gigabytes for cold war
and another eighty point seven gigabytes
for war zones so we could bring over our
modern warfare guns
now since then cold war and war zone
have been integrated it looks like ps5
players have had it rough also with some
tweeting that their cold war install
sizes are hovering around 227.9
gigabytes
it looks like you'll be playing a lot
more call of duty this year because you
really can't fit much else on your
[Music]
console
medal of honor above and beyond this
game just made it onto our list having
come out at the end of the year
and it did not disappoint this vr title
requires
340 gigabytes of free space just to
start the install
so why isn't it at the top of our list
well it eventually unpacks all the
assets down to a still whopping 177
gigabytes
for contrast our gamespot game of the
year half-life alex
also a vr title only takes up about 70
gigabytes
our fate is laid out before us jack
everything
that happened to get us here every
sacrifice that was made
they're all a part of this path quantum
break what happens when you aim to make
one of the best looking video games of
2016 for xbox one
that includes environmental destruction
motion capture and
an entire tv show you get 178 gigabytes
with the tv episode back and xbox one x
4k patch installed
and this was at a time when your xbox
one's 500 gigabyte hard drive could only
really use about 362 gigabytes of space
thanks to the size of the operating
system
final fantasy 15 windows edition final
fantasy xv featured a
huge open world road trips real-time
combat against iconic final fantasy
monsters chocobos
licensed coleman camping gear for some
reason
and even assassin's creed crossover dlc
you know what it also had a
massive installation size on pc on steam
it's listed as requiring 100 gigs of
storage space but the game is reported
to have an 85 gigabyte install size with
a 4k high resolution texture pack that
brings up to a 155 gigabytes
well it's official new zealand paid off
the client has given us cart launch
hitman 2's base game on steam starts at
around 60 gigabytes
but rapidly expands as you download
hitman's original legacy stages
this is because hitman 2 is really
hitman 1 plus 2 combined each of hitman
2's large and highly detailed
environments
is a sandbox full of crowds key
characters going about their daily
routines and all kinds of events
hitman 2 also has sniper assassin
missions similar to hitman sniper
challenge
if you want all that content installed
be prepared to download 149.62 gigabytes
on pc
even more interesting the upcoming
hitman 3 will also support the previous
two games levels
so it might end up even more massive
[Music]
[Music]
microsoft flight simulator if we were
looking at total data involved then
microsoft flight simulator would easily
take the number one spot on our list
you couldn't fit this game on your pc
now or anytime in the near future flight
simulator streams from two petabytes of
mapping data that's
000 terabytes being used to construct
planet earth with a draw distance of 370
miles
and real weather data being fed into the
game kind of amazing that it all fit
into a 127 gigabyte install on one of
our office pcs
with the roster of aircraft set to
expand and the possibility of
helicopters on the horizon
we can imagine the install size will
probably grow
all right halo master chief collection
next up if you notice the flood of data
on your xbox you know what i did there
then you probably have the halo master
chief collection
installed this title launched in 2015
and had a rocky beginning earning a 6
out of 10 on game spot with online
multiplayer that
barely worked it's since improved things
substantially and it's in a pretty good
place now
the game had a 59 gig install with a 20
gig day one patch and it only went up
from there
more has been added to the collection
and an enhanced version dropped in 2020
for next gen consoles
the install size is now clocking in at
125.9 gigabytes on one of our xbox
series x's
with odst and reach installed we all
know what needs to be done
get up close and personal with golf put
a bullet in his head
then maybe eat a sandwich destiny 2.
the next two games on this list are
going to be appreciated for their large
and also shrinking file sizes destiny
originally pitched itself as a 10-year
plan
and with destiny 2 doing seasons instead
of large expansions
it's looking like it might get there the
problem with a decade-long game however
is that as content gets added
file sizes grow this maxed out at around
the destiny 2 shadow keep expansion
which needed a reported 165 gigabytes
just to install on pc
the turning point in install size was
the recent beyond light expansion
that required a full redownload of the
game but shrunk install sizes
30 to 40 percent getting them to a more
manageable 59 to 71 gigabytes
in order to do this however bungie
straight up deleted worlds from the game
so less file size but at the expense of
some content being shelved for now
rainbow six siege can we just take a
moment to appreciate that tom clancy's
rainbow six siege came out in 2015
and it's still going strong the game
added a huge number of operators maps
weapons and reworked some of its
locations
they also finally got around to changing
the lord to chanka
all that being said the game previously
came in at over 100 gigabytes on pc
which includes the ultra hd texture pack
with the recent operation void edge
those install sizes have shrunk to
around a more manageable 70 gigs on pc
now who wants a sequel that looks just
as good as the original 2014 e3
presentation
i can't be the only one
good job guys yeah all right i'll get
her
when i started this project i thought
i'd be looking at massive games that
have been around
a long time like world of warcraft but
it turns out not too surprisingly that
most of the large game installs happened
recently
in future videos i'd love to go look at
the largest game installs relative to
their time
like wing commander price of freedom
with mark friggin hamill that came
out on six floppy disks so if you want
more videos like this make sure to
subscribe to our channel you have
yourself a great day